This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Veda Anthony. Flowers, candy, sappy love songs. Yep, Valentine's J is just around the corner. This week we're going to talk about the social science of Romance. We'll tell you how to save cash on an engagement ring. Turns out that the circumstances that surround the ring matter a great deal in about how much people are wanting to pay for it. And why it will be good for your marriage to buy that cheaper ring? We'll also explore the relative merits of a guitar case or a gym bag as props in an experiment on attraction. He's going to be like the pied piper, They're going to be following him wherever he goes. MUSIC
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦达纳姆。鲜花、糖果、肉麻的情歌。没错，情人节马上就要到了。本周我们将探讨浪漫的社会科学。我们将告诉你如何在订婚戒指上省钱。事实证明，戒指周围的环境在很大程度上决定了人们愿意为它花多少钱。为什么买那个便宜的戒指对你的婚姻有好处？我们还将探讨在关于吸引力的实验中，吉他盒或健身包作为道具的相对优缺点。他会像吹笛子的 Pied Piper 一样，无论走到哪里，他们都会跟着他。音乐
Anne Bowers is a professor at the University of Toronto. She studies how consumers determine how much to pay for wedding-related purchases. I was looking at how people sell wedding dresses, and what I noticed about how people sell wedding dresses is that it is a lot about the day. How happy their marriage was, how beautiful their wedding was,
安妮·鲍尔斯是多伦多大学的教授。她研究消费者如何决定为婚礼相关购买支付多少费用。我当时在研究人们是如何销售婚纱的，我注意到人们销售婚纱的方式很大程度上与那一天有关。他们的婚姻有多幸福，他们的婚礼有多美丽，
and they show a lot of photos that have nothing to do with the dress itself and a lot about the experience that they had. And I wanted to look at how that impacted sales, but it's hard to do that statistically. So I switched to looking at engagement rings. She looked at online sales of engagement rings. And if you've ever shopped for an engagement ring,
他们展示了很多与婚纱本身无关的照片，而更多地关于他们所拥有的体验。我想看看这对销售有何影响，但这很难通过统计学来实现。所以我转向研究订婚戒指。她研究了在线销售的订婚戒指。如果你买过订婚戒指，
you know that people buy engagement rings based on four things, cut color, clarity, and carrots. But it turns out that the circumstances that surround the ring matter a great deal in about how much people are wanting to pay for it. So I looked at about 1.5 million eBay transactions, and then I also ran an experiment of about 600 people, and I found that people really want to ring that they perceive as pure and not tainted, and
你知道人们买订婚戒指是基于四个标准：切工、颜色、净度和克拉。但事实证明，戒指周围的环境在很大程度上决定了人们愿意为它支付多少费用。所以我研究了大约 150 万起 eBay 交易，然后我还对大约 600 人进行了实验，我发现人们真的很想要一枚他们认为是纯净的、没有被玷污的戒指，
by tainted I mean from a failed relationship. In the experiment, Bowers offered the volunteers identical rings, but different scenarios. The first condition was a store condition where they said, we have excess inventory and so we're selling the ring. Then we also had a happy marriage condition where the person said, I'm really happily married, but I work with my hands and so I never wear this ring and that's why I'm selling it. And finally, we had a ring where they said,
我所说的被玷污是指来自一段失败的关系。在实验中，鲍尔斯向志愿者提供相同的戒指，但给出了不同的场景。第一种是商店情况，他们说，我们有库存过剩，所以我们在出售这枚戒指。然后我们还有一段幸福的婚姻情况，当事人说，我婚姻非常幸福，但我用手工作，所以我从不戴这枚戒指，这就是我出售它的原因。最后，我们有一个戒指，他们说，
I'm selling this because I got divorced and I'm never wearing it and you can have the ring for that. And those were the only things that differed. The ring itself was a .7 carat diamond ring with an original purchase price of $3,500. And Bowers asked people how much they would be willing to pay for the ring and how authentic they thought the ring was. So on average people priced the divorce ring at about $550 and they priced the happy marriage ring at about $780 and the store ring at about $820. But the interesting thing was it kind of reversed when you ask them about how likely they thought the ring was to be fake.
我卖这个是因为我离婚了，我再也不会戴它了，你可以因为这个拥有这枚戒指。这些是仅有的不同之处。戒指本身是一枚 0.7 克拉的钻石戒指，最初购买价为 3500 美元。鲍尔斯询问人们愿意为这枚戒指支付多少钱，以及他们认为这枚戒指有多真实。因此，平均而言，人们对离婚戒指的估价约为 550 美元，对幸福婚姻戒指的估价约为 780 美元，对商店戒指的估价约为 820 美元。但有趣的是，当你问他们认为戒指是假货的可能性有多大时，情况有点颠倒了。
And they found that the divorced ring they thought that was much less likely to be fake than the ring from the store of the happy marriage. The most interesting thing is that people were actually aware of this bias. And it's funny, I ask people in the experiment, you know, why did you price the way that you priced? And people would say things like, I know, I shouldn't believe this, I know it's just a ring, but it doesn't matter, I wouldn't be okay with this. It just feels wrong. And they can't really articulate why? Because they do know it's just a piece of metal, but it becomes really important in these settings. And that's true, even for people who really ought to know better. This project has been going on for some time, and I actually got engaged and married during
他们发现，人们认为离婚戒指是假货的可能性远小于来自商店或幸福婚姻的戒指。最有趣的是，人们其实意识到了这种偏见。有趣的是，我在实验中问人们，你知道，你为什么这样定价？人们会说这样的话：我知道，我不应该相信这个，我知道它只是一枚戒指，但这没关系，我对这无法释怀。这感觉就是不对。他们无法真正阐明原因？因为他们确实知道这只是一块金属，但在这些设定中它变得非常重要。确实如此，即使对于那些本应更清楚的人来说也是如此。这个项目已经进行了一段时间，我实际上在
the process, and I said to my husband, I said, Brian, you know, you've got to go and you've got to get a used ring. It's where all the value is. And he said, I can't do it. I don't care what your research is, I can't do it. I asked Anne how she could be so sure her fiance actually hadn't bought the tainted ring and taken advantage of the discount that came with it while telling her that it was brand new. That's a good point. That's a good point, and he is a very rational, strategic person, so he may have just known about the story. It's going to be an interesting dinner tonight. That's all I can say. And Bowers at the University of Toronto. Speaking of getting engaged, it isn't only lovebirds who are happy on Valentine's Day.
过程中订婚并结婚了，我对我的丈夫说，我说，布赖恩，你知道，你必须去买一枚二手戒指。这才是所有价值所在。他说，我做不到。我不管你的研究是什么，我做不到。我问安妮，她怎么能如此确信她的未婚夫实际上没有买那枚被玷污的戒指，并利用随之而来的折扣，同时告诉她这是全新的。这是一个好点子。这是一个好点子，他是一个非常理性、有战略眼光的人，所以他可能只是知道这个故事。今晚的晚餐会很有趣。这就是我能说的。多伦多大学的鲍尔斯。说到订婚，情人节快乐的不仅仅是热恋中的情侣。
A major source of happiness when it comes to romance is in setting up other people. I recently had a conversation with NPR's David Green about this topic. You know, matchmaking is something that far predates the internet. It's something that has been in every country and every culture for as long as we know. But now as computers and algorithms and websites,
说到浪漫，幸福的一个主要来源是为其他人牵线搭桥。我最近与 NPR 的大卫·格林就这个话题进行了交谈。你知道，红娘远在互联网出现之前就有了。据我们所知，在每一个国家和每一个文化中，它都一直存在。但现在随着计算机、算法和网站，
like OKCupid and Tinder and match.com, take over the job of setting up matches. There's new research that this might come at a price. NPR Social Science correspondent, Sean Cavanathan, is might come at a price. And Pierre Social Science course, Bonnetsch, over down them, is here to explain that price. What is a chunk? The price is really to matchmaker, David. I recently came by research by Laline Anika Duke University,
像 OKCupid、Tinder 和 match.com 这样的大型网站接管了牵线搭桥的工作。有新的研究表明，这可能会付出代价。NPR 社会科学记者肖恩·卡瓦纳森在这里解释这个代价。代价是什么？代价其实是给红娘的，大卫。我最近看到了杜克大学的拉琳·阿尼卡的研究，
along with Michael Norton. She finds that matchmaking is a significant source of happiness for many people. So here's what the researchers did. They examined the happiness of people who reported they like to play matchmaker and did it a lot against the happiness levels of people who didn't and they find that in general matchmakers are happier than non-matchmakers. I love that we actually don't care about
以及迈克尔·诺顿。她发现，对于很多人来说，牵线搭桥是幸福的重要来源。研究人员是这样做的。他们调查了那些自称喜欢当红娘并经常这样做的人的幸福感，并将其与不喜欢这样做的人的幸福感水平进行了对比，他们发现总的来说，红娘比非红娘更快乐。我喜欢我们实际上并不在乎
talking about the people who actually matched. We're talking about the happiness of the matchmakers but couldn't it be that just happy people tend to be the matchmakers? They decide to do this? That's right. So this is just a correlation. We don't know what's causing what. So to sort this out, the researchers ran a series of experiments where they had volunteers play matchmaker in a lab, and they find that the act of making matches increases happiness. They also find that when volunteers are given a chance to make unusual or unexpected matches, they experience greater boosts in happiness. And this probably explains why, if you're single, your matchmaker friends keep trying to introduce you to people with whom you have absolutely nothing in common.
谈论那些真正被撮合的人。我们在谈论红娘的幸福感，但会不会只是快乐的人往往会成为红娘？他们决定这样做？没错。所以这只是一种相关性。我们不知道是什么导致了什么。为了弄清这一点，研究人员进行了一系列实验，让志愿者在实验室里扮演红娘的角色，他们发现撮合的行为会增加幸福感。他们还发现，当志愿者有机会做出不寻常或意想不到的撮合时，他们的幸福感会得到更大的提升。这可能解释了为什么如果你单身，你的红娘朋友会一直试图把你介绍给那些你和他们完全没有共同点的人。
These they really want to accomplish something by finding that unlikely duo that could come together. That's exactly right. Well, Schacher, if people were sort of relied on these matchmakers to make these unexpected unusual matches because it makes them happy, is that sort of going away? These computer algorithms are now, you know, not really finding those unusual duos? That's exactly right, David. Many of these computer algorithms are designed to match people who are similar to them. So people actually can go to these websites and say, I want someone
这些人真的很想通过找到那个可能走到一起的不可思议的二人组来完成一些事情。完全正确。嗯，沙查尔，如果人们有点依赖这些红娘来做出这些意想不到的、不寻常的撮合，因为这让他们快乐，那这种现象是不是快要消失了？这些计算机算法现在，你知道，真的没有找到那些不寻常的二人组吗？完全正确，大卫。其中许多计算机算法旨在将彼此相似的人撮合在一起。所以人们实际上可以去这些网站说，我想要一个
who has exactly the same interest and personality and characteristics that I do. And so the computers are finding matches. They're not finding unusual connections. And as I read the study, David, I realized that we have lots and lots of websites for single people to find partners. What we might really want is a website for matchmakers so that they can continue to make these really unusual matches. I'm not sure it would increase the happiness levels of single people. It would probably increase the happiness levels of matchmakers. And a few single people who would find these unexpected matches.
和我拥有完全相同的兴趣、个性和特征的人。所以计算机正在寻找匹配项。它们没有找到不寻常的联系。当我读到这项研究时，大卫，我意识到我们有大量供单身人士寻找伴侣的网站。我们真正想要的可能是一个供红娘使用的网站，这样他们就可以继续进行这些非常不寻常的撮合。我不确定这会提高单身人士的幸福感水平。它可能会提高红娘的幸福感水平。以及一些会找到这些意想不到的匹配的单身人士。
Yes, I can tell that you're a matchmaker at Heart David. I am. Great to be matched with you this morning. Take care, Sunker. Thanks, David. at Heart David. I am great to be matched with you this morning in this video. Take care, Sunker. Thanks, David. When we come back, Dan Pink returns for another round to stop what science will share some interesting research about what makes couples compatible,
是的，我看得出你内心是个红娘，大卫。我是。很高兴今天早上能与你匹配。保重，尚卡尔。谢谢，大卫。当我们回来时，丹·平克将再次回归，探讨科学将分享一些关于是什么让夫妻相容的有趣研究，
and why it might be less about chemistry and more about vocabulary. Stay with us. Back now for another round of stop-watch science, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm joined as always by Daniel Pink, our senior stop-watch science correspondent. Welcome, Dad. Thank you, Shankar. On stop-watch science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting social
以及为什么这可能较少关于化学反应，而更多关于词汇。请继续收听。现在回到另一轮“秒懂科学”，我是尚卡尔·韦达纳姆。和往常一样，加入我的是我们的资深“秒懂科学”记者丹尼尔·平克。欢迎，丹。谢谢你，尚卡尔。在“秒懂科学”中，丹和我互相给对方 60 秒的时间来总结有趣的社会
science research, as we approach the 60-second mark our producers, Kara and Maggie, will bring up the music to drown us out just like they do at the Oscars. Our topic today is love. Dan Pink is widely known as the Love Guru. And so, Dan, I can't wait to see what you have discovered for Stop what Science. We're going to give you insights into why we love, who we love, and also, once Dan stops laughing, how to make love laugh. The only person laughing harder at that is my wife.
科学研究，当我们接近 60 秒大关时，我们的制作人卡拉和玛吉会放出音乐来把我们的声音淹没掉，就像他们在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上做的那样。我们今天的主题是爱。丹·平克被广泛称为爱情大师。所以，丹，我迫不及待地想看看你为“秒懂科学”发现了什么。我们将为你揭示我们为什么爱、我们爱谁的见解，以及在丹停止大笑之后，如何让爱笑。对此笑得更大声的人只有我的妻子。
All right, love guru. If you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Now this February 14th, millions of Americans are expected to pop the question, but which of the resulting marriages are likely to last? In October, two Emory University economists tackled that question. They surveyed more than 3,000 people, controlled for a bunch of demographic and social variables,
好吧，爱情大师。如果你准备好了，你的前 60 秒现在开始。在这个 2 月 14 日，预计数百万美国人将向伴侣求婚，但由此产生的婚姻中，哪几对最有可能长久呢？去年 10 月，埃默里大学的两名经济学家解决了这个问题。他们调查了 3000 多人，控制了一系列人口统计和社会变量，
and found, and I'm quoting the paper's abstract now, that marriage duration is inversely associated with spending on the engagement ring and wedding ceremony. Wow. In other words, the more money a couple spent on the wedding or the ring, the more likely they later were to split up. Now, the researchers found only a correlation.
并发现——我现在引用这篇论文的摘要——婚姻持续时间与在订婚戒指和婚礼仪式上的花费呈负相关。哇。换句话说，一对夫妇在婚礼或戒指上花的钱越多，他们后来分手的可能性就越大。现在，研究人员只发现了一种相关性。
They don't say that a lavish ceremony or a six-karat diamond causes divorce. Not at all. And the correlation wasn't perfect in all cases. However, the economist did find a tight connection between cheap celebrations and longer marriages. And that's intriguing, especially in a world where a multi-billion dollar wedding industrial complex urges young people to declare their love by breaking the bank. That is really interesting, Dad. Of course, what this means is that wedding planners, jewelers, and florists will never sponsor
他们并不是说豪华的仪式或六克拉的钻石会导致离婚。完全不是。而且在所有情况下，这种相关性并非都是完美的。然而，经济学家确实发现，简单的庆祝活动与更长的婚姻之间存在着紧密的联系。这很耐人寻味，尤其是在一个价值数十亿美元的婚礼工业复合体敦促年轻人通过倾家荡产来宣告他们的爱意世界里。这真的很有趣，丹。当然，这意味着婚礼策划师、珠宝商和花店将永远不会再次赞助
hidden brain ever again. Although I should point out as the love guru that you do have a sponsor that the mattress company. That's about it. All right, here's my theory on why it is the researchers found what they did. If you are deeply, truly, madly in love with someone, you might not actually need a big ring,
《隐藏的大脑》。尽管作为爱情大师，我应该指出，你确实有一个赞助商，那就是床垫公司。差不多就是这样。好吧，这就是我对研究人员为什么会发现他们所发现的理论。如果你对某人爱得深沉、真挚、疯狂，你可能实际上并不需要一枚大戒指，
or a big ceremony to prove your love. On the other hand, if your kind of sort of maybe possibly in love with this other person, you might actually use the ring or a lavish ceremony to compensate for this hole in your heart. Whoa, hold on the heart. It's an interesting argument. You have a some kind of emotional deficit and you cure it with what economists call signaling.
或者一个盛大的仪式来证明你的爱。另一方面，如果你对另一个人只是有点、稍微、也许、可能有一点喜欢，你可能会实际上用戒指或豪华的仪式来弥补你心中的这个空洞。哇，等一下，关于心。这是一个有趣的论点。你有一种情感赤字，然后你用经济学家所谓的信号传递来治愈它。
Exactly. Could be, they actually had a much more pedestrian reason for it. They said that expensive weddings cause people to go into debt. Debt causes stress in a marriage and marriages with stress are more likely to break up. More pedestrian. I think I like the whole in the heart theory a lot better. Speaking of a hole in my heart, I'll have a hole in my heart if you go over your time. You're 60 seconds, starts right now. Alright, psychologists and economists have long known about an interesting phenomenon
完全正确。也可能是这样，他们其实有一个更平庸的原因。他们说昂贵的婚礼会导致人们负债。债务会导致婚姻压力，有压力的婚姻更容易破裂。更平庸。我想我更喜欢心中的空洞理论。说到我心中的空洞，如果你超时的话，我心中就会出现一个空洞。你的 60 秒现在开始。好吧，心理学家和经济学家很早就了解了一种有趣的现象
called the endowment effect. Basically, when something comes into my possession, I think of it differently than before I owned it. So I might be willing to pay $10 for a mug, but once I own the mug, I want $20 to part with it. Thomas Wallston and Collette Nataf at the University of Maryland recently applied this idea to the dating market. They find that when they offered men and women
叫做禀赋效应。基本上，当某样东西进入我的Possession（所有权）时，我对它的看法就会与我拥有它之前不同。所以我可能愿意花 10 美元买一个马克杯，但一旦我拥有了这个马克杯，我就希望别人出 20 美元才肯割爱。马里兰大学的托马斯·沃尔斯顿和科莱特·纳塔夫最近将这个概念应用到了约会市场。他们发现，当他们向男女提供
profiles of potential partners, people demonstrated the endowment effect. They were willing, for example, to spend $4 to buy the contact information of a man or a woman, but they wanted $10 to sell the contact information to someone else. Curiously, the researchers found that women are especially prone to this bias. There was one guy for whom women on average were willing to spend $3.97 to buy his contact information, but they wanted $23.50 to sell the contact information to someone else.
潜在伴侣的个人资料时，人们表现出了禀赋效应。例如，他们愿意花 4 美元买一个男人或女人的联系方式，但他们想要 10 美元才肯把这个联系方式卖给别人。奇怪的是，研究人员发现女性特别容易产生这种偏见。曾有一个男士，女性平均愿意花 3.97 美元购买他的联系方式，但她们想要 23.50 美元才肯把这个联系方式卖给别人。
Now since the endowment effect is primarily about loss of version, meaning people care more about losses than about gains, it suggests that women may experience more loss of version when it comes to potential dating partners than do men. Now, I don't know what the moral of the story is then, maybe find someone who is as unwilling to part with your phone number as you are unwilling to part with theirs. I'm just hoping my contact information is worth more than three or four bucks. But you think there's an inevitably on a study like this, one could offer an evolutionary explanation for the reproductive strategies of women and men being different.
现在，既然禀赋效应主要是关于损失厌恶的，这意味着人们更关心损失而不是收益，这就表明在潜在约会对象方面，女性可能会经历比男性更多的损失厌恶。现在，我不知道这个故事的寓意是什么，也许找一个像你一样舍不得对方电话号码的人吧。我只是希望我的联系方式能值三四块钱以上。但你认为对于这样一项研究来说是不可避免的，人们可以为女性和男性的生殖策略不同提供一种进化解释。
Is that what's going on here? You know, I think the authors speculate that that might be at play. I have to say that I myself am skeptical about that because I feel like it's really difficult to disentangle what biology is telling us to do from what culture and our social norms are telling us to do. But speaking of biological and cultural imperatives,
这真的是这里发生的事情吗？你知道，我认为作者推测这可能在起作用。我必须说，我本人对此持怀疑态度，因为我觉得真的很难将生物学告诉我们要做的事情与文化和我们的社会规范告诉我们要做的事情区分开来。但说到生物和文化当务之急，
Dan, your next 60 seconds starts right now. If you're like me, Valentine's Day always brings to mind two words, assortative mating. That's the term scientists use to describe when living creatures, including human beings, mate with those who are like themselves. Over the last half century, there's been an upsurge in assortative mating in the US. In particular, people with college degrees are beyond, are now much more likely to marry other people with college degrees are beyond are now much more likely to
丹，你的下一个 60 秒现在开始。如果你和我一样，情人节总是让你想起两个词：同类婚。这是科学家用来描述生物（包括人类）与自己相似的人交配的术语。在过去的半个世纪里，美国的同类婚激增。特别是，拥有大学学位及以上学历的人，现在比 20 世纪中叶更有可能与其他人结婚。
marry other people with college degrees are beyond than they were back in the mid-20th century. So, what does this mean for America? Well, for economists, led by Jeremy Greenwood of the University of Pennsylvania, analyzed data from hundreds of thousands of US households between 1960 and 2005. Using some complicated math, they made a startling discovery. Had the US more or less maintain the marriage patterns of 1960, when people were more likely to marry those with different levels of education, income inequality today would be about 21% lower. Put another way, one explanation for rising inequality
更有可能与拥有大学学位及以上学历的人结婚。那么，这对美国意味着什么呢？由宾夕法尼亚大学的杰里米·格林伍德领导的经济学家分析了 1960 年至 2005 年间数十万美国家庭的数据。利用一些复杂的数学，他们有了一个惊人的发现。如果美国或多或少地保持了 1960 年的婚姻模式，当时人们更有可能与受教育程度不同的人结婚，今天的收入不平等将降低约 21%。换句话说，不平等加剧的一个解释是
is that marriage is becoming more socially stratified. You know marriage is a private choice of course, but what this research tells us is that private choices cannot public consequences. I'm wondering, Dan, is it possible that the researchers are seeing these findings because the number of women, especially who are graduating from college, is very different today than it was 50 years ago. Could we be seeing this merely because more women are college graduates and therefore more people who are college graduates are going to be marrying one another? Yeah, not merely because, but that's
婚姻正变得更加社会分层。你知道婚姻当然是一个个人的选择，但这项研究告诉我们，个人的选择不能没有公共后果。丹，我想知道，研究人员看到这些findings（发现）是不是因为女性（尤其是大学毕业的女性）的数量与 50 年前相比有很大不同？我们看到这一现象会不会仅仅是因为更多的女性是大学毕业生，因此更多拥有大学学位的人将彼此结婚？是的，不仅仅是因为这个，但这是一个
a big part of it. And you add that to the fact that they're more women in the labor market and that they're increasing returns in the labor market to education. And what you have is you have these very, very positive trends that create another trend that is less positive, because you have the well-educated, marrying the well-educated, and pulling away. The solution, to my mind at least, is to make sure we raise all boats. So speaking of boats, you need to hop in your canoe
很大的部分。再加上劳动力市场上有更多的女性，以及劳动力市场对教育的回报不断增加。于是你拥有的是这些非常非常积极的趋势，它们创造了另一个不太积极的趋势，因为受过良好教育的人与受过良好教育的人结婚，并拉开了差距。在我看来，解决方案至少是确保我们水涨船高。所以说到船，你需要跳进你的独木舟
for 60 seconds of paddling that begins right now. All right, I take back what I said about Dan being the love guru because he clearly knows very little about romance. Everyone knows the most important words when it comes to Valentine's Day are not a sort of mating, but language style matching. James Penny Baker, the University of Texas Austin and colleagues at Wayne State University, Texas A&M and Northwestern University, recently analyzed transcripts of conversations between dating couples and also instant messages exchanged by the couples.
开始 60 秒的划行，现在开始。好吧，我收回我之前说丹是爱情大师的话，因为他显然对浪漫知之甚少。众所周知，情人节最重要的词不是同类婚，而是语言风格匹配。德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的詹姆斯·佩尼贝克以及韦恩州立大学、德克萨斯农工大学和西北大学的同事最近分析了约会情侣之间的对话记录以及情侣之间交换的即时消息。
They find that when couples use the same kinds of language or mimic one another's sentence constructions, they are more likely to hit it off. That could mean being interested in a second date, it could mean taking in a relationship over the long term. Now, we don't know what's causing what. It's possible that when people are attracted to one another, they start using similar language. It's also possible, similar language somehow drives attraction. The clear implication of the study is that when you peer into your date's eyes over that candlelit dinner on Valentine's Day, make sure you transcribe the conversation, and analyze it for clues.
他们发现，当情侣使用相同类型的语言或模仿彼此的句子结构时，他们更有可能一拍即合。这可能意味着有兴趣进行第二次约会，也可能意味着长期的恋爱关系。现在，我们不知道是什么导致了什么。当人们互相吸引时，他们可能会开始使用相似的语言。也有可能，相似语言不知何故推动了吸引力。这项研究的明确含义是，当你在情人节那天在烛光晚餐中凝视着约会对象的眼睛时，请务必记录下谈话，并分析其中的线索。
When your date asks you what you are writing, say that you are testing him or her for pronoun, preposition, and article compatibility. You know what, that's actually how I met my wife. No, no, that's fascinating. It's so consistent with other research showing the power of mimicry. Not only is something that we can fact,
当你的约会对象问你在写什么时，说你在测试他或她的代词、介词和冠词的相容性。你知道吗，这其实就是我认识我妻子的方式。不，不，这太迷人了。这与展示模仿力量的其他研究非常一致。不仅是我们能够做到的事情，
but something that we do naturally when we have an affinity with somebody. That's exactly right. All right, so there you have it. Find someone who loves your phone number and will never part with it. If you marry someone who comes from the same social and educational background as yourself, remember that it can have big societal consequences. If you want your next date to go successfully, match your date's pronouns, prepositions, and conjunctions. Finally, buy your date's pronouns, prepositions and conjunctions. Finally, buy your fiancé a cheap ring,
而且是我们对某人有好感时自然而然会做的事情。完全正确。好吧，事情就是这样。找一个爱你电话号码且永远不会放手的人。如果你和一个与你有相同社会和教育背景的人结婚，请记住这会产生巨大的社会后果。如果你想让你的下一次约会顺利进行，请匹配你的约会对象的代词、介词和连词。最后，买你的代词、介词和连词。最后，给你的未婚夫买一枚便宜的戒指，
get married at City Hall and say, darling, Dan Ping told me to do it this way. All right, so I've gone from the love guru to the divorce doctor. I guess we just broke up, Dan. Y'all, it hurts me. I'm holding my heart. All right, thank you so much, Dan.
在市政厅结婚，然后说，亲爱的，丹·平克让我这么做的。好吧，所以我从爱情大师变成了离婚医生。我想我们刚刚分手了，丹。大家，这让我很痛心。我正捂着心口。好的，非常感谢你，丹。
Shankar, always a pleasure. Happy Valentine's Day. Happy Valentine's Day to you. I'm joined by my friend Michele, the Indie mom of comedy, for a segment that we call mad scientist. Welcome Michele. Thank you Shankar. Michele, I'm going to give you the outlines of a research study and you have to figure
尚卡尔，这绝对是我的荣幸。情人节快乐。也祝你情人节快乐。加入我的是我的朋友米歇尔，喜剧界的独立妈妈，我们将带来一个我们称之为疯狂科学的环节。欢迎米歇尔。谢谢你，尚卡尔。米歇尔，我将给你概述一个研究课题，你必须弄清楚
out what the study found. Wow. Are you ready to put on your lab coat? I am so ready to put on this fictitious lab coat. So glad it's fictitious. Alright, so there's a man who walks around this city in France. He's pretending just to be a guy on the street, but in reality he's running an experiment. He stops a series of women and he says the following thing to each of them.
这项研究所发现的是什么。哇。你准备好穿上你的白大褂了吗？我太准备好穿上这件虚构的白大褂了。真高兴它是虚构的。好吧，有一个男人走在法国的这座城市里。他假装只是街上的一个普通人，但实际上他在做一个实验。他拦住了一系列女性，并对她们每个人说了以下的话。
He says, hello, my name is Antoine. I just want to say that I think you're really pretty. I have to go to work this afternoon and I was wondering if you would give me your phone number. I'll phone you later and we can have a drink together someplace. Here's the catch me, shall. When Antoine goes up to some of the women, he's holding a guitar case. When he goes up to others, he's holding a big sports bag, a gym bag. Alright, so some of the women think that Antoine is a musician, others might be led to believe that he is an athlete of some kind or he's into physical fitness. The question is, does carrying the guitar case or the gym bag make any
他说，你好，我叫安托万。我只是想说我觉得你真的很漂亮。我今天下午要去上班，我想知道你是否愿意把你的电话号码给我。我稍后会给你打电话，我们可以找个地方喝一杯。问题来了，米歇尔。当安托万走向其中一些女性时，他拿着一个吉他盒。当他走向其他人时，他拿着一个大的运动包、一个健身包。好吧，所以有些女性认为安托万是一位音乐家，另一些人可能会被引导去相信他某种程度上是一名运动员或他喜欢健身。问题是，携带吉他盒或健身包会不会产生
difference to whether the women give him their phone number and which one do you think makes a difference? Wow, that is so interesting, Shankar. I'm sitting here. My head was spinning as you were describing the actual study. I was just like, okay, where is he going? I'll tell you this much. I think that with the guitar he's only going to draw a certain kind of person and I think those people are kind of far and few in between. I think with the the gym bag, everybody wants someone who they deem is healthy or cares about their health. And even if he's not a professional athlete, I think he's going to get a little more rhythm, if you will, with the gym bag, because he's going to look like he cares about his body and he cares about his health. I think the women that see him
对女性是否给他电话号码有任何影响，你认为哪一个会产生影响？哇，这太有趣了，尚卡尔。我正坐在那里。当我听你描述实际研究时，我的头都在转。我当时想，好吧，他要去哪儿？我这么跟你说吧，我认为拿着吉他他只会吸引某种特定类型的人，而且我认为这些人相当少见。我认为拿着健身包，每个人都想要一个他们认为健康或关爱自己健康的人。即使他不是职业运动员，我认为拿健身包也会让他更有律动感，如果你这么说的话，因为他看起来像是在乎自己的身体和健康。我认为看到他的女性
with the guitar are going to be a very different kind of woman, but he's in France. So he's in France. How did I forget that? Oh my gosh, this changes everything, Shunker. He's in France. This dude is gonna be racked up with numbers with the guitar. What? The French don't care about fitness. They eat baguettes all day. If you eat a lot of bread, clearly,
拿着吉他将是非常不同的一类女性，但他现在在法国。所以他在法国。我怎么把这个给忘了？哦，天哪，这改变了一切，尚卡尔。他在法国。这家伙拿着吉他肯定能记下一堆电话号码。什么？法国人根本不在乎健身。他们整天吃法棍。如果你吃很多面包，显然，
you're not preoccupied with health and wellness. So I, you know, I'm gonna take that back. He's in France. He's going to kick all kinds of you know what with the guitar. He's gonna get every one many meets and the study will show that the French have a Proclivity for artists and particularly those who can and if it's acoustic, jeez Louise. If it's acoustic, he's gonna be like the Pied Piper. They're gonna be following him wherever he goes. I'll go with that. I'll go with he's gonna get more women because it's France,
你不会全神贯注于健康和保健。所以，你知道，我要收回刚才的话。他在法国。他会拿着吉他大显身手。他会赢得他遇到的每一个女人，研究表明法国人格外偏爱艺术家，尤其是那些能……如果是原声的，天哪。如果是原声的，他会像 Pied Piper 一样。无论他走到哪里，他们都会跟着他。我就选这个。我选他会赢得更多女性，因为这是法国，
he's an artist and they're really into that. All right, this was a study by Nicholas Gagin and his colleague, Selene Jacob and Lubomir Lamy. And they find that more women share their phone numbers with Antoine when he is carrying the guitar case. Thank you very much. It took me a second to get there, Shankar, but when I thought about the country, I have to say that your reasoning process was fascinating.
他是一个艺术家，他们真的很喜欢那一套。好吧，这是尼古拉斯·加金和他的同事塞琳·雅各布以及卢博米尔·拉米的一项研究。他们发现，当安托万提着吉他盒时，更多的女性会把她们的电话号码分享给安托万。非常感谢。我花了点时间才反应过来，尚卡尔，但当我想到那个国家时，我不得不说你的推理过程太迷人了。
I don't know whether the same results would be found in the United States. So your theory is that this is actually not being driven by gender differences between men and women. These are cultural differences that might be unique to France. Absolutely. That was Michelle, the Indy mom of comedy. Go online to find her new album, Funny as a Mother. And if there's any French listeners, please disregard my remarks about you guys not caring about your health. I just did a little informal, just data collection in my brain and I thought of baguettes and I thought of croissants. I mean, there's so much bread there. The Hidden Brain Podcast is produced with love by Karam Agar Kalasen, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak.
我不知道在美国是否会得到同样的结果。所以你的理论是，这其实并不是由男女之间的性别差异驱动的。这些可能是法国独有的文化差异。绝对是的。那是米歇尔，喜剧界的独立妈妈。上网去寻找她的新专辑《Funny as a Mother》。如果有任何法国听众，请忽略我关于你们不关心健康的言论。我只是在脑海中做了一个非正式的数据收集，我想到了法棍，想到了牛角面包。我的意思是，那里的面包太多了。隐藏的大脑播客由卡拉·玛加·卡拉森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克·内斯特拉克满怀爱意制作。
For more Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and on your local public radio station. Also, subscribe to our newsletter. Send us an email to hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line. We might even send you a love letter. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Instagram 以及您当地的公共广播电台关注我们。此外，请订阅我们的newsletter。发送电子邮件至 hiddenbrainatnpr.org，并在主题行中写上单词 subscribe。我们甚至可能会给你写一封情书。我是尚卡尔·韦达纳姆，这是 NPR。《隐藏的大脑》本期节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。